bonsoir banques se mouiller cissé merci
de répondre à nos questions avec l'
annonce de la mort d'une centaine de
djihadistes au cours de l'opération
éclipse a mené par les forces françaises
et maliennes
la mission barkan est-ce qu'elle redore
son blason bonsoir oui effectivement on
espère que ce genre d'émission va
perdurer
parce qu'il y avait une certaine
lassitude de la part des maliens ce que
vous savez après huit ans de après
l'engagement de la france lors de
l'opération serval il ya en santé une
situation d'enlisement et aujourd'hui
dieu merci on voit que il ya une montée
en puissance et qui est cette opération
conjointe avec des résultats probants et
on espère enfin que ce genre d'émission
va perdurer dans le temps et bouter les
trop riches mordus du tutorat mallya est
généralement du sahel la région
justement du sel on rappelle qui
regroupe cinq pays mali tchad burkina
faso mauritanie niger est ce qu'elle est
suffisamment sécurisé pour envisager un
retrait progressif des forces françaises
puisque emmanuel macron l'a évoquée lors
des traditionnels voeux à l'armée à
florence parly la ministre française
désarmé l'a dit également pour t'en
souviens il ya environ un an à pau il y
avait un sommet et la france envoyait
600 hommes supplémentaires
dans la région oui bon sens en tout cas
le ressenti sur le terrain fait
qu'aujourd'hui le retrait des forces
étrangères n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
et quand on voit les dialyses qui
continuent de circuler librement dans
des verres au mali au niger au tchad en
mauritanie au burkina
je pense que le retrait de la france
elle doit ce prêt à l'aider à se
préparer et doit ce programme et qu'on
nous laisse le temps de monter en
puissance au niveau de notamment du g5
du sahel et aussi des forces ma gueule
parce que moi je parle en tant que
malien mais le président ne précipitons
pas les choses
laissant le temps au temps je comprend
un tube et la lassitude de des français
mais aussi de quelques mois dernier qui
disent que oui la france doit s'en aller
mais non la france va ça n'allait dans
des pôles commission et le laisser un
peu un pays sécurité mais pour l'instant
la 7e bien changé en un an
une cinquantaine de soldats français
tués au sahel oui exactement donc cela
tue c'est à dire que les opérations sont
menées
si on perd des hommes sur le terrain
c'est qu'une délibération de sang mêlé
donc ça signifie aux mythes
malheureusement que la situation
sécuritaire n'est pas encore aussi loi
pouvait l'espérer il ya la force
européenne également takouba déploiement
d'unités d'élite européenne qui doit
prendre le relais de la force barkan
dans la région est ce qu'elle peut
suffire à assurer le maintien de la paix
au sahel et au mali
notamment que vous représentez oui je
pense que la fausse pape ou pas et les
forces du g7 usa n 6 continents un
spécimen les mêmes actions connu il
répond on obtiendra des résultats
probants
on a vu ce plan ce qui le parc anne et
les forces maliennes se mettent ensemble
avait vu il ya une centaine de de dia
dix tués alors si si [ __ ] contingent
européen et maliens qui se mettre
ensemble on aura oui des résultats
probants
ça j'en suis certain on l'a dit les pays
du g5 sahel se réunissent les 15 et 16
février à n'djamena la capitale du tchad
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre de ce
sommet qu est ce que vous vous vous
attendez le cnt conseil national de la
transition malienne j'espère que nous
allons de rassurer en tant qu'africain
si bien d'avoir de l'aide xp et
extérieur mais à un moment donné il va
falloir compter sur nous mêmes il va
falloir que le g5 monde
en fait en puissance et que le g5 sera
réellement déployés sur le théâtre des
opérations
on ne peut pas toujours compter sur la
france où les unités européennes pour
nous sortir de cette situation
il est temps que les pays du sahel se
donnent la main et puisse permettre g5
d'avoir les moyens financiers techniques
pour combattre les dyades y seront sur
leur territoire on l'a dit tout à
l'heure
bein dos le président du conseil
national de transition que vous
représentez a également a été reçue tout
à l'heure par emmanuel macron à l'elysée
en france une visite de trois jours
qu'est ce qui va se passer exactement
pendant ces trois jours pour votre
président où on est là la transition
mon politique au mali alors la
transition politique se passe très bien
les trois organes exigé par la cedeao
ont été mises en place donc à présent la
république
un vice président de la république fait
un chef de l'état et le gouvernement
et aujourd'hui je suis membre du cnt le
conseil national de transition qui
devient l'organe législatif donc oui la
transition s'ils sont pauvres
il reste encore 13 à 14 mois pour
essayer de mettre le mali sur de bons
rails quant à la visite du peleton bada
ou en france c'est une visite attendue
et naturel je dirai ce que quand on
connaît l'histoire entre ces deux pays
là est d'autant plus l'histoire récente
il est normal que le président de la
transition
ces rôles seront sur place pour une
visite de travail et il y a
il apparaît dans ce cadre merci à bam se
mouiller si c'est d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
membre du conseil national de la
transition malienne